was already pretty crazy here at Trey
and everybody just wanted to see what
they had to offer and I was here for
that I got the chance to see him both
rockets
get down the floor intercepted
one for Trent Duvall again driving great
defense right now is little right there
coming on the weak side crossing the
lane getting a nice blood they're down
now by the way to 63% from the field
that's still incredible but having shot
close to 78 and that's big for Naza too
easy
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this I mean come on
rebound in the throwdown
all the way in
scoop won't go but it's their little
there for the Fox what he has to be
right know if anybody seriously consider
drafting him getting everyone's
attention said this man it's never is
good ensues easy the dude he's dunking
on a seven feet any consciousness what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content